we've seen already we've talked about
already I should say the idea that we
can use these functions we've been
looking at recently by the way what kind
of functions what kind of functions are
we looking at trigonometric functions
thank you we can use these trigonometric
functions we have discussed very briefly
we haven't really looked at it in much
detail the fact that you can use these
functions you can use these graphs to
model all kinds of situations and I
think some of the examples just off the
top my head I think we looked at like
electromagnetic radiation all of it is
in a wave I think we looked at I don't
think we said tides I think what he said
temperatures these kinds of things right
anything where there's an oscillation up
and down and up and down or left and
right if you like you can use these
trigonometric functions to model what's
going on and that's really what we're
going to drill down into today treat
electric functions as models of actual
situations and the first instance where
you look at is when you've been staring
at since you walked in this of course is
a it's a mouse wheel it is a wheel of
some kind
it's a ferris wheel it's a ferris wheel
and it's spins and spins and spins and
what we can do is we can model or you
know we can model the motion of this
ferris wheel using a trigonometric
function now what I'm going to do is
provide some details to you which I'm
starting off here and we're going to
construct an equation that will model
this now I'm going to say right out the
gate usually you will get given a model
you'll get given an equation you just
have to interpret it but we're gonna use
technology to be able to produce this
equation ourselves and in the future
when you see the equation I want you to
I'm saying oh this is what the bits mean
rather just get handed it and like oh I
don't know how does this work so here's
the first wheel I'm going to stop it for
a second because it's distracting me
because it's spinning so fast I'm gonna
give you a few pieces of information
they'll tell us everything we need to
know about this ferris wheel so first we
need to know how big it is so I'm going
to give you the radius of this
particular ferris wheel we're interested
in its
35 meters from the center of the wheel
to any of the points on the edges we
also need to know how fast it's moving
so when you're describing a Treena
metric function which aspect of it I've
given you a clue which aspect of it
describes the speed of the motion what
we call that for a trigonometric
function what's the period talking about
how fast it goes its period right so
this is how long does it take to
complete one full cycle one full you
know round of motion so this particular
ferris wheel it's got a 90 second
rotation so every one and a half minutes
you know you start at some point and
that's going to come back round to the
original point okay we need one more
piece of information I think which is
you remember that Ferris wheel right
it's kind of raised off the ground we
should hope otherwise it's gonna collide
on the bottom so the point at which you
get on I'm just going to call it the
loading point the point at which you
board the ferris wheel it's two meters
above the ground two meters above the
ground so that's how its suspended and
it can spin freely sort of we're talking
about phases we get into this we'll come
to that briefly what I want you to do is
I'm with your technology there oh I
shouldn't have mentioned this as well
when you were opening canvas I'd also
like you to open a tab for desmos
because that's all we're gonna use to
construct our model here okay right now
we're going to use a trigonometric
function to model the motion of this
ferris wheel now we've got two different
Trina metric functions that we'll do the
up and down up and down up and down
right what are the two functions sine
and cos right we could honestly we could
use either of them for reason is it
going to become clear in three to four
minutes I'm gonna ask all of us to start
with cause so go ahead and type in cos x
I've got my cos right there
okay so this might cause X now quick
thing we're actually talking in terms of
you know something moving around
according to time so normally we have an
x axis to represent horizontal and a y
axis here but I'm actually going to
suggest that instead of this being I'm
gonna move it over to a more useful spot
like that instead of this being an x and
a y axis when representing the height of
the ferris wheel so rather than a y axis
what might be called the vertical axis
for height how about H for height okay
so I'm gonna call this the H axis and
because I'm thinking about this as time
passes what do you think I should call
my horizontal axis T for time okay so
we're we're awake now welcome to Monday
okay so I've got a hide axis I've got a
time axis and what I want to do is take
this regular old cause function it would
actually I'd write it as cos T when I'm
writing up and unfortunately desmos just
wants X's and Y's we're going to fiddle
with this regular function to get it to
fit all the information that we want
okay so for starters at the moment this
represents something going up and down
and up and down we're representing the
height as time progresses what's the
highest that this particular first word
goes it goes up to one right and
apparently this is also an underground
Ferris wheel because it goes down to
negative one okay so we want to change
that don't wait right
what we want is for the you know extent
of the motion to be much bigger than one
and negative one we want it to be 35
right so what can I do how can we modify
this equation or this expression anyway
um so that it doesn't go up one negative
one I wanted to have a radius of 35 so
how shall I adjust the equation okay
let's try plus 35 so I'm going to chuck
a plus 35 over here plus 35 so the first
thing that happens is I cannot see where
my Ferris wheel is gone you're gonna
have to zoom out and you might as well
do this now because we're gonna have to
do it eventually
there it is well let's get my access in
the right spot roughly anyway all right
we go why did I put my H in my T in such
an open spot I'm gonna have to put it
there
okay so
this was Frank's suggestion it's done
something was this what I wanted this
was not what I wanted at least I'm not
below ground that's good but what could
I do
instead Alisha you had a hand up you're
just stretching okay you've got you've
like realized something else doesn't
right that's exactly what are you
thinking 35 over two at the front here
okay let's try that mm-hmm should I get
rid of the plus 35 for now I'll do what
will come back to that okay so let's do
that and I'm gonna take exactly
suggestin here multiply 35 was it 35 and
you said every two okay so what we got
here is this sort of more like what I
wanted well certainly I have a bigger
range of motion with Sarang suggested
suggestion what we did was we took the
same range of motion and then we just
moved the whole thing up into the air
right now I am going to move things up
in the air in a minute but that's not
what I wanted at the time is this giving
me a radius of 35 hmm I'm getting some
nods and I'm getting some shakes ishani
what are you thinking
you're shaking at me
ah ok so at the moment right like I'm
presuming that 17 and a half that's 35 /
- right so I'm going from 0 up to 17 and
a half and then I'm also going down to
17 and a half so this thing the highest
it goes is 17 and a half above the
center and the lowest ago is seventeen
half below and that's a radius of 17 and
a half do you agree so if we want a
diameter of double of that actually we
kind of did extra work here instead of
35 on two I should just have just 35
we'll do okay so let's fix that up hmm
all right so okay now Alicia's like no
wait a second
we've still got this problem of our of
our ferris wheel going below ground that
was the problem right now you're
absolutely right we fixed some things
not all of them right so I'm gonna come
back to sir anxiety now we've got this
this Ferris was the right size it's
going up the right amount it's going
down the right amount there's that 35
right there but we don't want it to be
an underground Ferris wheel so how do I
fix it Strang was actually on the right
track well what do you think
okay let's try adding 35 this is
actually this is actually back to what
sarang suggested right and then we'll
we're gonna investigate your thought all
right let's have a look okay so have a
look here's my first moon now this is
looking better this is looking better
I'm not underground anymore but um this
ferris wheel is gonna have some serious
problems every every few seconds gonna
have some problems what's gonna happen
this ferris wheel yeah it's just gonna
whoever's like well actually everyone at
some point is gonna hit the ground real
bad right so will how we gonna fix this
okay
we've we've already added 35 but if I
add 2 to that well it's actually I'm
gonna be even lazier oh yeah okay how's
a look now are you happy with this it's
the right range of motion I'm not
colliding with the ground anymore and
we've actually even though I didn't
mention it we've gotten one of our other
pieces of information and sort of
included that what was the piece of
information that well I haven't I'm
sorry I'm about to get to the period
what's the thing I've already accounted
for will added to where'd he get to from
yeah very good this is the
West Point on the ferris wheel okay so
so far so good